ja ja was geht hier ist max und herzlich
willkommen zur heutigen folge minecraft
nero ab auf den server jetzt schon den
hintergrund den trittbrettern bitte ist
es jetzt okay ist es lag schon wieder
total einig ich hab mich ja bei mir oben
ausgelaugt sehr gut leute also ich
schreibe erstmal bei global schließlich
ja allerdings müssen wir das wir haben
wir haben einiges vor so ich die längst
schon wieder so ein bisschen
ich gucke ich mal wieder beim vertritt
rein ich will wild wieder ein bisschen
leid mir holen war ganz kurz weil heute
geht es darum ob sie den zu fahren und
dann in den nationen
das sieht leider nicht so gut aus
aufgerufen hat effect 3 leben halt
direkt am start
richtige maschine
fix ist am start okay dass ich ein
bisschen glück gerade so lass mich
überlegen nehme ich mein gutes schwert
mit auf jeden fall weil die stimme von
spawn eine höhle mit büchern
aber ich meine jetzt auch in den never
done heftiger ich will es halt nicht
verlieren wenn ja wird wirst aber selbst
sterben nicht gestört
heja gut ohne schwert da ich schon dass
mass effect den etat auch anders ist ist
er
haben sie da nicht die maxime player und
checken was ist alles geht was okay es
ist nicht so schlimm also weil es geht
halt fehlt aber nach wie vor noch extra
so dann packe ich erst mal ein bisschen
essen zum braten rein
so zeigt eine karotte muslimvertreter
aufbewahren und dann gehe ich auch schon
runter in die höhle und checkt das ganze
aus bombay und mauro hat mir nicht
geantwortet das werden wir merken aber
auch den server bisschen mehr
grafikspeicher zugewiesen auf dem server
also stark beschädigt
die gute okay ich weiß ist allerdings
nicht genau wie viel zeit ich jetzt
dadurch noch habe ich hoffe mal dass ich
nicht irgendwie grob wasser stoße
irgendwie jetzt nach 17 minuten lassen
ja gut ich war gerade eine minute auf
server als gefühlt so ok wo geht es
jetzt hier rein äußerlich messen ich
hab' ich habe mich einfach glücklich aus
der höhle rossi damit habe ich mich
einfach straight nach oben raus gebauten
wasser einer habe ich dabei klafft aber
gefunden
okay da ist auch schon das erste
bisschen lava aber das ist nur wird der
soers blog gewesen
valiant recht portugal klingt nicht gut
sechsstellig so erging es da jetzt
runter
klar du kannst sieht so aus als wäre es
hier lang gehen
das komme auch sehr bekannt vor von uns
beiden wo ich gerade bin so etwas liest
ich habe noch kein gas gefunden recht
nicht mir keine angst so hier sind
überall lava aber ich brauche ja 8
also da in der schoko in der ersten
folge die wir gefunden haben
da ist ja ob sie deren habe ich auf die
abgebaut ach du hast ja schon okay ich
bin sehr gut dass es noch schöner
gewesen welche fährt runter gefallen
heisst klar leute so dann wird sich
jetzt hier ein bisschen obsidian gegönnt
dann schaffen wir es heute wohl ein gast
einstellung ja man muss halt immer mit
dem schlimmsten rechnen
ja da habe ich auch definitiv com
ich habe gar keine blöcke dabei mega
stress ist so jetzt aber wie viel
insgesamt ich glaube ich war eben hier
bei boss an sich nur direkt überall
runter lava fließt wenn man hier an der
kante steht dürfte nichts passieren ich
kann mich auch direkt löschen
deshalb gehe ich jetzt einfach mal ein
bisschen risiko
ich finde einfach keinen des retro
röhrig league würdig zu den meterweit
empfinden fisch schmecken den schalke
fans haben die das display sondern
andere dimensionen sich jetzt aus
bislang ist ohne spaß machen ab ich hab
so angst dafür jetzt keinen kein gas
tritt ohne spaß würde ich den gas finden
könnten wir heute und jetzt noch fliehen
in der heutigen folge sagen das ist kein
spinner finde dann wie die ganzen
wandler mops
vielleicht habe ich einfach glück und
das direkt am portal ein normalerweise
jeder mensch hat einfach nur angst vor
gas und ich bin einfach unbedingt
fünften alte die sache die du brauchst
also wenn du ein gas mit topchancen
szene die schon hoch aber
hundertprozentig klar und extrem hoch
aber als rechtens
ja also so wirklich unwahrscheinlich ist
es definitiv nicht
kannst ja mal kannst mal im wiki
nachschauen was ich prozent das hat er
ja ich habe bisher glück noch kein
könnten noch nichts verloren vom portal
dann packe ich das einfach neben der
einst würde ich sagen dass wir so ein
portal platz haben oder so kannst du
machen wobei warte mal wie viel brauchen
wir noch für den finnen in chaman table
die habe habe ich aber schon meiner
kiste sonst hätte ich das noch schnell
gemachte er du kannst ihn einfach in
einer nächsten folge die duh aufnimmst
meine bücher nehmen und dann machst du
einfach so ein gemeinschaftsstand und
table da lass ich mich auf dem feld
einen baum aus einer kiste hab ich dich
brauchen kennt dann leute einfach wieder
ab nach oben
die sich schon seit der autoshow
ich habe angst dass sie nicht mehr sein
kann
warum sollten sie nicht natürlich beide
server ausgehen wird so wieder aber auf
den server ich weiß ich habe zeit
verliere ich denn jetzt bitte gerade
ja absehbar dass die ewigkeit ich kann
von der aktuellen aufnahme locker fünf
minuten abziehen will ich wirklich
geschätzt sagen so ab auf die solvenz
jetzt wieder sagt in welschen stiege die
anderen denken was für sound alter
längst erwachsene zum dritten mal
geträumt
ok so leute leben leid noch mitnehmen
oder ist nicht so selten
stegaurach berlin
daher stimmte dann geht es jetzt ab nach
oben leute kann ich mich hoch stecken
das muss man ja besten sowieso mit
wasser oder ich schwimme hier vorne
einfach hoch und dann baue ich mich
einfach direkte straight nach oben
letzten klinik handelseinig direkt da wo
du bist das metall ist im kern findet
zufällig hier ist hier ist sehr direkt
apple gab machte total.com
aber da unten das portal nee ich will
dass schon der start von iad kannst du
später verletzten in der stadt zu crysis
nicht
ja aber er ist richtig sagt gemacht ja
klar macht halt macht noch mit bostons
richtig lange apple einfach abbruchs
diese lockern blind aber aus dem staub
ich hab den grammys mit hand abgebaut
der ist nämlich einfach mit nach oben
und dann brauche ich den einsätzen er
dabei immer wieder ab so wie viel ich
hab noch 14 fehlern
das heißt ich kann mir auf jeden fall
jede menge verkraften
ich könnte mir eigentlich ja gut ich
habe auch strings also ich würde jetzt
einfach ich weiß halt nicht es ist so
stressig das jetzt nicht weiß wie weit
liegen wie viel ich noch auf dem platz
und habe ich im sommer so 14 gremmel mit
dass ich jeden fall der kelle das zeug
habe
rhodos zu sorgen wie bei sonja den hat
auch gestern in wie als den hat gestern
war die wahl zwischen kampf und wollten
sich weder hatte auch zu den derzeit
seien betroffen
aber man kann ich man kann nicht von
zombie sterben assistenz und ach ich
hatte zum echten zombie kann pech haben
aber du brauchst ja richtig pech dieser
stelle möchte ich nur oh fans sagen so
zack da kann ich es gerade jede menge
hochlaufen
also macht ok nadja wieder den normalen
weg hoch gefunden
das kleine bäume oder thema zum
richtigen eingang gebaut
okay leute ich bin wieder oben jetzt
wird das portal gebaut
ok ich hab' ich würde jetzt schätze ich
ja noch zehn minuten nicht so viel nicht
nichts
ich habe 15 aufnahmen hat locker 38
minuten
ja wenn ich nicht runter vielleicht kann
ich ja noch weiter aufnehmen oder ist
ist bis zur unterwäsche unterwegs echt
fertig haben die nicht irgendwie heute
noch darüber geredet dass ich habe mit
der regel kippen gerät waren das ist
nachdem also ich hab es auch und so
verstand dass wenn man ist zb 20 opengl
fehler willst du mich töten
oh gott ich habe gerade den letzten
block setzen wollen von fucking portal
ich habe an meinem pc davor durch gips
leute so kein scheiß ihr habt eine folge
der brände ich hab aufgenommen und der
leaf ewigkeiten weil ich vergessen hat
ihn auszumachen von meinem abi und jetzt
stürzt er mir fünf mal in der aufnahme
ab willst du mich
die leute so ein letztes mal auf dieser
bitte jetzt nicht irgendwie in welle
zwischen oder so schon wieder der
komische sound dort wieder ewigkeiten
weil er wenn du den mieter sterben wird
ist so jetzt auch noch nicht verbrannt
sind dann laden die ähnlichen weg wie
komisch
so habe ich hier kein eisen komm schon
das legt leute was ist das denn hier
richtig schnell war die reinholen hast
du ein essen am stark essen dann aber
muss ich halt schnell hin dass holen ok
zack und zack fünf stil sitzt so ich
würde mir noch jemand hast du noch was
von da ist ja auch noch jede menge fun
so ok oft verdammt es nervt mich so
übertrieben bau dieses lecks und so
leute ist tut mir wirklich leid aber ich
kann absolut gar nichts für dass das
jetzt nicht so optimal läuft ich würde
echt gerne mehr geschafft haben und ich
möchte auch zumindest noch in den neckar
in dieser folge der server wird
wahrscheinlich in vier minuten offline
gehen falls es so ist wie wir befürchten
g13 schicken habe ich
warum war es normal dass linda gebracht
ich wollte mir noch eine pigs machen
halt schnell löschen
hast du holz gucken aber top nicht wenig
eine schaufel bombay hat gerade den
server verlassen
ja sagt ihr nur froh dass ihr eure
ganzen folgen so wie es plant beenden
könnte so was mache ich denn ich bin so
unkonzentriert ist auch dadurch dass ich
mir so ein stress mache und auch gott
machen leute zu einer wirklich ganz okay
ich will also das mindeste was wir heute
noch machen werde wenn bitte schließt
aber der server nicht um punkt 0 uhr das
wäre so stressig r wird von brent so
bisschen holz noch mitnehmen
ich würde mir jetzt so was von selbst
schlagen wenn er jetzt gerade ein
gastransport und ich direkt vom server
fliege sobald ich drin wenn erst mal
rein da chance dann ja ähnlich
geburtstag
trotzdem okay ich hab in den niederrhein
ob ich dafür bin ich zu lange gedauert
so was auch immer sein ziel war ja ich
habe auch ein bisschen schiss geht der
netter sieht sehr interessant aus und
ich bin direkt bei einer structure
response wenn also das ist irgendwie
einer festung oder so total koordinaten
screenshot also ich würd mir verrückt
machen ständig prügel wenn du wenn du
riskierst du bist da weiß was ist das
für ein monster
oh mein gott was ist das für ein wesen
mit 880 leben wobei das ja nicht so viel
aber das ding ist riesengroß
ich werde jetzt auch nicht kämpfen
ich werde probieren videos gesagt hast
mich noch kurz einzubauen
oh gott da geht's direkt runter kam hier
gerade gar nicht einbauen
märz den schweizer kanton karten zack
zack zack zack zack zack rein hier rein
so sind die sonne blicken
ich bin den safe eigentlich drin so ok
ich verstehe es überhaupt nicht dasselbe
ist wie eine sonne pigments in einer
wahl fällt irgendwie mich verguckt ist
direkt auf mich zugelaufen ein geländer
ich bin ich bin eingefahren noch ein
bisschen ich mache gerade ein bisschen
flink fahren ich dass ich halt nächste
folgen für mich zufolge einige teile
habe sagte den betroffenen mieter das
sehr gefällt ist
wenn es aber um was die amber geistes an
es spuckt lava an bis ins boot
dort wirken wie gefährlich ist in der
natur erschrocken des todes die
spielzeit ist nun um leute was war das
bitte für eine folge
ich weiß nicht wie viele minuten ich
verloren habe ich wurde gerade gekickt
nächste folge werden wir fliegen